Here's another interesting
word problem that was
sent by [? Cortagio ?].
A woman cycles to work
alongside a railroad track
at 6 kilometers per hour.
That's an interesting
piece of data.
6 kilometers per hour.
Every day she arrives
at a crossing the same
time that a train does.
OK.
One day she was 50 minutes
late, and was overtaken by
the train 6 kilometers
from the crossing.
In how many minutes will the
train reach the crossing.
Let's see if we can draw a
diagram here that can somewhat
describe what's going
on in this problem.
So what's on a normal day?
On a normal day, she leaves
from home, she leaves from
home, and she goes and she
travels alongside
a railroad track.
Not too different than my own
commute on my own bicycle.
Actually, I actually do travel
on a bike path that's right
along a railroad track.
Anyway, let's say she leaves
here at time is equal to 0.
Time is equal to 0.
And right at this point right
here, maybe that's where the
railroad crossing is, right
there, the train passes her up.
And she's traveling at
6 kilometers per hour.
And what else does it tell us?
It doesn't tell us how
long it takes her, or
how far she travels.
So let's just say she arrives
here at t is equal to a hours.
t is equal to a.
We'll do time in hours, since
we're in kilometers per hour.
So this path takes her
a hours to travel.
So it takes her a hours.
If we care about
the time, a hours.
Now on this next day,
she's 50 minutes late.
So on this day, she has to
travel the same distance in
time, well in both
distance and time.
But this is this day.
She leaves not a t equals 0.
She leaves 50 minutes late.
Since we're dealing with
hours, let's write
50 minutes in hours.
So she leaves at-- if this was
time equal 0, that's when she
normally leaves --she's now
leaving at that time is equal
to 50 minutes, or time
is equal to 5/6 hours.
Right?
50 minutes is just 50/60 hours
or 5/6 hours of time is
equal to 5 over 6 hours.
This time is equal to 0 hours.
And let's see, it says that she
was overtaken by the train 6
kilometers from the crossing.
So she was overtaken by
the train some place over
here, and this distance.
Right this is where the
crossing is, that's
that crossing.
This is 6 kilometers.
6 kilometers.
In how many minutes will the
train reach the crossing?
So if we can figure out some
way of expressing this time, if
we can figure out with this
time is, we know that the train
reaches the crossing
a t is equal to a.
So if we know this time, we
can just find the difference
between these two times and we
would have solved the problem.
So let's see if we can
figure out this time.
So we know that it normally
takes her a hours to travel
this whole distance.
It doesn't matter when she
leaves it takes her a hours.
So in this case it should
also take her a hours.
And how long does she have to
go when the train passes up on
this day that she was late?
How long will it take her to
go this distance right there?
Well she's traveling at 6
kilometers per hour, she
has to go 6 kilometers.
So in time, this is going
to take her 1 hour.
To get-- you know, the train
will have long passed her --but
to get back to the crossing,
she's going to have to
travel for another hour.
So if her whole route takes her
a hours, this whole length
in time is a hours.
Then this distance right
here is going to have
to take her, what?
She has an hour left, her whole
trip is going to be a hours, so
this is going to be
a minus 1 hours.
Let me scroll down
a little bit.
This is going to take
her a minus 1 hours.
So if on the day she was late
it took her a minus 1 hours to
get passed by the train, what
time are we talking
about right here?
What time is this?
This is t is equal to--
well we started at 5/6
--t is equal to 5/6.
That's where we started.
Plus the amount of hours she
traveled plus a minus 1.
So there we, I think, we now
have all the information we
need to solve this problem.
On the day she is late, the
train passes or at time is
equal to 5/6 plus a minus 1
hours, where a is the amount of
time it normally takes her to
travel her entire route
to the crossing.
We know that the train passes
this point at t is equal to a.
So if we want to know how many
minutes does it take the train
to go from this point to
this point, we just have to
subtract the two times.
So the minutes it takes,
well the hours because
we're doing it hours.
And remember I said 50 minutes
was 5/6 of an hour, so the
minutes it takes is a,
that a, minus this.
Minus 5/6 plus a minus 1.
Right?
That's just the difference in
time for the train, in hours.
So this is a minus
5/6 minus a plus 1.
Luckily the a's cancel out.
a minus a, and you're left with
1 minus 5/6 hours, which is
just equal to 1/6 hours.
There are 60 minutes
in an hour, so 1/6 of
that is 10 minutes.
So it takes the train 10
minutes to get to the
crossing from the point
that it passed her.
Another neat problem, and
I thank [? Cortagio ?].
for that.
And then you can actually use
this information if you want
figure out how fast the train
is going, or you could even
think of other types of
derivative problems
off of this one.
Anyway, another good problem.